hi there today we'll look at reformer
the efficient transformer by Nikita ETF
Lukesh Kaiser and Ansem loves gaia this
is a paper that tries to reduce the
extreme resource requirements of the
transformer model now if you haven't
seen the transformer model before that's
this thing I suggest you go watch for
example my video on it attention is all
you need it's called where the
transformer is introduced the most
famous transformer is called Burt BER T
and you can also look that up I've made
a video about this so what's the issue
here if you remember transformers they
need a lot of memory and why that's
because they compute in each layer they
compute these attention things let's
recap surely in a transformer you
propagate information layer by layer so
you have layer here with some signal and
then the next layer that you try to
propagate the signal now what you do you
assign you assign key queries to each of
the next layer so each of the next layer
has queries and queries are just vectors
this is a vector this is a vector this
is a vector and so on so basically the
next layer has the ability to ask to ask
the last layer what it wants this is a
kind of an intrinsic property of
attention and I as I said I explained
this in detail in the video attention is
all you need basically these are what's
called queries queue and then this layer
is exposing what are called keys and
keys again are vectors so vector vector
vector vector and so on so keys are
vectors and the way that the information
is propagated to the next layer is when
a
whatever we consider for example this
node here right this node let's make
that yeah when we consider this node
here it is going to look in the last
layer which which keys match my key the
most and in this case it would probably
this key and this key right they match
the key the most and here we look at the
inner product so the angle between the
vectors and then information is
aggregated by simply having a weighted
average of the values so information is
coming in here and here actually
information is coming in to all the
nodes but since only these keys match
the information will be propagated like
this to this unit we can do this for
another unit for example this unit right
here what's the value of this unit well
we have to look at the key here which
key is it going to be matched to it's
probably going to be matched to this key
right here and probably no other key
really maybe this key a little bit so
the information of that node in the next
layer will be whatever's informations
coming in here routed there and a little
bit of this information so this is kind
of a it's not a hard it's a what's
called soft attention so there's a
little bit of information going
everywhere but the majority of the
information is coming from the nodes
where the key is much so these are
queries these are keys and technically
these things coming in here are called
values but Jim imagined the values
simply as the information to be
propagated and the queries and the keys
are responsible for routing that
information to the next layer all of
these things are learned so the queries
the keys and the values now what's the
problem the problem is between the
queries and the keys as you can see what
you have to do is you have to match
every single query with every single key
in order to find out
formation goes so this becomes order of
wood if you have d keys and the queries
order of d squared operations that you
have to do and of course d squares
values that you have to compute and
since these are all vectors of course
there is D will not only be the number
of keys but then again this is
multiplied so there is an inner
multiplication with the dimensionality
that's called a capital D of the know
sorry that's not an inner multiplication
um let's just remain at this
so these squared inner products between
vectors of capital D dimensions so it's
not an it's not an easy thing for
resources to do you need a lot of
resources to hold this all of this in
memory at the same time and to compute
all of these things the reformer aims to
solve this problem so this this giant
space problem that the transformers have
space memory also computational problem
to a lesser degree mostly it's a it's a
memory issue all right so what is
happening here and you see you you see
here that this this product between two
matrices clearly gives you this kind of
squared squared thing so what's
happening in the reformer to do this the
trick is the trick is like if we go back
to this drawing the trick is to create
what's called a hashing scheme or
buckets and in creating buckets what you
want to do is you want to group similar
things together so let's say we create
four buckets bucket one bucket two
bucket three bucket for right and each
bucket we label and bucket one we label
the up Direction is with right direction
with a down direction the left direction
as vectors and now we simply put each of
the things into the bucket where it
belongs most so let's for example this
vector here it goes here sorry that is
like absolutely not the right place
it goes probably here right this vector
here probably this one goes here right
and so on so you'll end up each of these
assigning a bucket so this these these
all go into into that bucket let's
continue actually let's also put the the
keys in the same buckets so also the
keys this key here probably goes to this
bucket this key here probably goes to
this bucket let's say this key here
probably goes to the bucket over you
already see so before right before we
cared about this particular query and
this particular key we just looked and
we said those two will probably route
information to each other because
they're similar and now you can see they
both ended up in the same bucket so the
idea is to create a scheme where you
throw these things into buckets such
that if two vectors are similar they
will end up in the same bucket with high
probability so you'll only have to
really compare things within the same
bucket and not across all of these d
squared elements that's the idea
and the technique here is called
locality-sensitive hashing so
locality-sensitive hashing and short
this is called LSH
the idea is the following if you have
two vectors v1 and v2 and they have and
you have a distance measure distance
measure D D is a distance what you want
is if the distance between V v1 and v2
is small I'm going with small then you
want the stem in the same bucket and if
the distance is large then you want them
in a different bucket different buckets
you know with high probability so all of
these things where you say you want them
in the same bucket with probability P
with probability P with high probability
P and here you want them in different
buckets with high probability or you
want them in the same pocket with low
probability that's an equivalent form of
stating this is all formalized and I can
direct you to the Wikipedia page of that
it's pretty good
if it's a concise definition here you
can see that and it gives a number of
examples so one example I like to give
here for locality sensitive hashing is
of course the scheme of bucketing will
all depend on what your distance measure
is if you consider the distance measure
simply to be the jacquard distance so
let's say we have two vectors 0 1 and
here we have 1 0 1 1 0 1 and here it's 0
alright so maybe you can see the first
two vectors here are
much more close together than the the
last vector now in terms of bit
differences right one scheme to do
locality-sensitive hashing is to simply
sub sample bits so in this case this is
a slightly constructed example we will
just sub sample the first two bits and
then construct the buckets according to
these bit values so if we since we
sample two bits we have four buckets
right this here is 0 0 here is 0 1 here
is 1 0 and here is 1 1 that's the
concept of locality-sensitive hashing
you have these buckets right and then
you can say alright this vector has 1 0
goes into this this goes into this and
then that goes into sorry the 0 1 bucket
right and you end up with what you have
you have the 2 closed vectors in the
same bucket and the too far apart
vectors in that bucket of course that
doesn't always work you know you can be
unlucky in subsampling but that's kind
of trade off you'll have to to go for
right if things that are close together
happen with it's a low probability but
if they happen to end up in the
different buckets then basically you
lose the fact that they are close to
each other and you know that's the trade
of the kind of locality-sensitive
hashing they use in the reformer now is
what are called random projections so
let's say you have a bunch of vectors
and that's really what we care about
right you have a bunch of vectors and
what you want you want the keys and and
queries so you have a bunch of vectors
like this and you want to create buckets
such that vectors that are close
together will end up in the same bucket
and vectors that are far apart you will
end up in the in different buckets the
way a cool way to do is and this is in
the cosine distance so we care about the
angle between vectors right it's a cool
way to do this is to use random plain
projections
and this the the cool thing about it is
it works for the cosine distance and you
can basically choose how many buckets
you create right let's say we want to
create four buckets here again what we
need is two hyperplanes and what we'll
do is so here is the origin will simply
create two hyperplanes through the
origin at random so I'm gonna draw a
random hyperplane here like this and
then a second random hyperplane ah like
this alright so you would agree those
are pretty random hyperplanes as much as
I can be a random generator and then
we'll simply label so this will label
hyperplane one this will label hyper
point - right and now we simply assign
each vector bits according to the way in
which on which side of the hyperplane
they lie so let's call this here the
plus side and this here the minus side
or even yeah let's call this the plus
and the minus and here also we call this
the plus side and this is the minus side
so this vector here is its signs are
plus plus right because it's on the plus
side of both of hyperplanes
this vector plus plus this one plus plus
this one here is called it's on the
negative side of point two but on the
positive side of plane one so it's plus
- this one here - - - - - - and these
are your buckets so you would group
these vectors together because they have
they have the same science it would
group that vector you would group these
vectors together the combination of this
with attention since in attention you've
seen attention uses a soft Max and the
soft max is dominated usually by the
largest elements and since we compute
inner product
it means that the softmax thing is
dominated by the by vectors that have
small inner products so basically you
don't have to look at all of these d
squared vectors if you can find the ones
that are have the closest distance you
can pretty much ignore the others and
LSH allows you to do this so build
buckets of vectors with the with similar
directions then you only have to care
about these vectors comparing them to
each other so that's not a lot of
vectors generally and that's how you
save a lot of work so you will only have
to care about these three vectors if
your key vector for example is right
here you'll only have to care about
these things in the same bucket and you
can ignore all of that rest of the space
of course the more hyperplanes you have
the more pockets you'll have the less
vectors you'll have in the same bucket
that's the general idea
I find this explanation to be a bit easy
you can equivalently explain it by doing
these kind of random rotations in this
space you can think about how that will
end up actually being the exact same
thing is what I just explained I just
like that my explanation better I think
all right
so the way they use this they have an
illustration right here is the following
so they have these keys right sequence
of queries and keys so they do
equivalent queries and keys which is the
thing you can do in transformers don't
worry too much about it whether they're
different or not but then they do this
LSH pocketing and here the color of the
cell is just the bucket the LSH bucket
which will end up and they sort that all
right as you can see and now they do an
additional thing which is called they
chunk the as you can see there are not
the same amount of vectors in each
bucket and that is
sometimes a problem because even though
you've you've reduced the memory the
memory is still the memory requirements
are still dominated by the largest
pocket right by whatever bucket has the
most number of vectors that will pretty
much be your memory requirement because
now you don't you don't have to if this
is D right you have to compute all the
DS squared things anymore but you'll
only have to compute this quantity let's
call that B so max the maximum bucket
size but that could still be large right
if you look at a distribution it's
probably going to be something like this
right where most buckets have a kind of
a standard number of vectors but some
buckets will have a lot of vectors and
that's sorry some few buckets will have
a lot of vectors and your memory
requirement is still dominated by this
so they do an additional thing which is
called chunking which means they'd
actually take fixed size chunks here
fixed size here they always take four
and they say all right these are our
chunks and we will only compute
attention within the chunks right so it
could be that there there's the same
bucket is actually split between chunks
and that's why they do an additional
thing is that you can attend to things
in a different junk right right here all
right you can attend to things in your
neighboring chunks so you're restricted
to either your own chunk or your
neighboring chunk note that there aren't
any any arrows going over here so you
can you can attend they have this
diagram here which things you can attend
to you can attend to yourself or attend
to your neighboring thing but not to any
other thing or the other way around
right so that's basically the the
concept of saving memory now your memory
quirements are if we call this quantity
now we called the other one B let's call
this the chunk size C right your memory
requirements are pretty much C squared
plus whatever this unidirectional so not
these digit isn't squared plus probably
off see something like this so you bring
your memory requirements down quite a
bit
now that's the the general idea here the
problem they face again is so they face
another problem where they say hold on I
can't find it right here they say hold
on we we do have actually another
problem and that is that these
transformers have to back propagate so
you'll have to forward propagate these
things and now we've come to solve this
D square computation issue but what
you'll have to do is if you go from
layer to layer right layer layer layer
layer what you have to do is if you
propagate information forward you still
have to back propagate and in order to
back propagate usually usually you'll
have to remember all of these
activations right so these activations
these activations in order to do back
prop it is often the case that you
actually have to remember the
activations because in each forward
propagation in each layer here you might
lose some information
imagine you have a you have to a layer
that map's these two-dimensional vectors
both to so here actually let's make this
blue Maps these three vectors to the
following configuration so a layer Maps
these vectors to this this and this so
it maps two things to one thing which
which you know can
be if you in in a linear layer it can
decide to map it to a lower dimensional
subspace so you could actually sir I
decide to map it to in fact two points
right this is also a possibility could
do dimension reduction so because all of
this in order to do Bachrach you
actually have to remember these things
in order to do proper a back prop this
is a problem again for the transformer
because all these activations even
though we've gotten rid of the d square
computation they will have to be
remembered and that takes a lot of
memory the way to solve this is actually
to do invertible layers what that means
is that if i propagate information
forward forward forward forward I can
figure out what the information here was
simply by looking at the back propped
activations and this is this happens if
the layer is invertible so if this
function here is invertible so if f here
technically is invertible so i can
actually write down the inverse of f and
that is defined this of course is a
pretty big restriction and the way they
achieve it I like to go to the blog here
the way they achieve it is they do
what's called an idea from reversible
networks where they always have two sets
of activations that's what you see here
x1 and x2 and in each layer only one of
them is updated in a residual fashion so
you can see here layer one updates x2
but x1 remains the same and goes to y1
right and then in the next layer layer 2
only updates Y y1 in order to construct
z1 but why to remains the same to be z2
and then you can revert the layers you
can think we could figure out what the
activations were from the back prop
signal now that's extremely good if you
want to save memory but of course it
restricts clearly you have to be
restricted to this kind of architecture
or similar this idea actually isn't new
this has been used many times in things
like normalizing flows and I want to
highlight this paper I actually want to
highlight specific I chose this paper
because they have these nice diagrams
where they show exactly this you see
they have two sets X 1 and X 2 that in
forward propagation they only update one
of them and then in backward in what's
critical inverse propagation they can
figure out what those were and they
couple these in exactly the same way
like here this drawing might be even
more similar where they alternate
between updating the two activations so
you can think of this as a way to simply
make the function that you're
representing with the neural network
invertible that is a giant constraint on
your architecture but these methods here
these normalizing flow methods use that
so they can actually define an
invertible layer because they need the
Jacobian inverse in order to compute
their normalizing flow so you see that's
why they originally did it and I'm sure
that that's not a like a new idea or
it's particularly new again strangely I
haven't found the the any of the flow
literature cited they do cite the
reversible residual net paper that they
probably got the idea from alright so
with these two things now you can save
the giant computation right and you can
also not store
the forward activations so they say they
can take now giant giant giant input
sizes
you may remember transformers like Burt
so Burt it can use something like 512
tokens in in its input sequence that
means it's the sequence that you can
look at with Burt at a time is 512 long
and not a bit longer right there have
been some extensions to that for example
I believe in Excel net so Excel net has
pushed this to something like C times
512 where C is a smallish constant that
that where you can kind of carryover
information between sequences but this
thing here as you can see they calculate
it can take up something like 64,000
tokens and it that would use in total 16
gigabytes of memory which is available
on a high end GPU
right so this is a giant this is a giant
step forward in in producing
transformers that can actually take
large models and here you see that
memory and time complexity you can look
at these things yourself but we you can
see maybe here that these squares here
India from the original transformer they
now vanish from this and all of these
constants are a lot of these constants
are actually smaller for example that
chunk size is in there instead of kind
of the entire sequence length so that's
basically the the paper they show that I
can actually input those long sequences
they can apply this to images you see
there's image
Genet pixel-by-pixel which is a lot of
pixels and would have been absolutely
unthinkable with one of the original
transformers and with that I invite you
to check out the paper and the blog post
and I'll see you next time bye-bye